dans cet hôpital de kiev le vaccin est
attendu avec impatience
l'ukraine compte un million deux cent
mille cas de covile 19 et près de 22000
mort pour 40 millions d'habitants c'est
aussi l'un des pays les plus pauvres
d'europe dont le système de santé est
vieillissant pour ces médecins
le vaccin est donc la seule solution
bien sûr le monde entier attend
l'arrivée du vaccin certains l'ont déjà
humé l'ukraine attend toujours et il est
assez compliqué de savoir combien de
temps encore nous allons attendre
l'arrivée du vaccin
nous espérons vivement que la
vaccination permettra de mettre fin à la
pandémie et que les médecins qui étaient
d'un des sous spécialité et doivent
aujourd'hui traiter des patients
atteints du coc vides pourront reprendre
leur travail initial dans une sous
spécialités qu'ils exerçaient auparavant
les autorités se veulent rassurantes
dans le cadre du programme onusien
kovacs 8 millions de doses sont promises
et si l'efficacité du vaccin chinois
corona vac est confirmée entre 1,9 et 5
millions de doses pourront être livrées
dans une allocution le président
zelensky assure que la campagne de
vaccination pourra commencer le mois
prochain en acier nous avons de bonnes
nouvelles concernant le vaccin contre le
coc vie de 19
la vaccination débutera en février nous
prévoyons que l'ukraine recevra bientôt
un million de doses de vaccins le
premier million d' une société
internationale de premier plan
nous serons en mesure d'annoncer les
détails sous peu speed son gros pour
résumer je peux dire que la situation
est stable contrôler et pas aussi
menaçante qu'au printemps
mais ces millions de doses commandées
sont bien insuffisante pour vacciner 40
millions d'ukrainiens à titre de
comparaison la pologne voisine a réservé
près de 60 millions de doses pour ses 38
millions d'habitants
l'opposition et les élus pro russe
critique la stratégie du gouvernement et
lui reprochent son manque d'anticipation
il reste bien une solution pour obtenir
un vaccin plus rapidement faire appel à
la russie et à son vaccin spoutnik v
pour l'heure impensable aux yeux du
président ukrainien en conflit avec
poutine sur la question de la crimée